Canada is the richest country on Earth
run by idiots and I hate to say that as
a Canadian because I have a passport
right but I'm also Irish and I'm also
emirati he is one of the most successful
politicians in history he's been in that
seat forever he has zero executional
skills he is a horrible manager he
perhaps is the worst manager Canada's
ever been under the absolute worst it
can't get worse absolutely a negative
10. if you have employees you need to
check out the ERC program Chef wonderful
why Mr Wonderful because it's cash flow
that you don't have to pay back good to
know this guy's so smart and so handsome
go to wondertrust.com to see if you're
eligible